elle était encore épargnés jusqu'à cette
nuit ni pro s'est réveillée sous les
bombes d'après les services de secours
trois frappes aériennes russes ont
touché un jardin d'enfants un immeuble
résidentiel et une usine de chaussures
faisant au moins un mort la quatrième
ville du pays est située sur le dniepr
fleuve à l'est duquel se trouve la
partie la plus russophone du pays
aujourd'hui quasiment encerclée par les
troupes russes dans le nord de cette
région kharkiv deuxième ville du pays
connaît l d'intenses bombardements
depuis dix jours cette nuit c'est un
institut pour personnes handicapées
situé dans les faubourgs de la ville qui
aurait été touché à l'intérieur de
kharkiv déserté par la majorité de son
million et demi d'habitants ceux qui
sont restés se terre dans le métro des
conditions de vie de plus en plus
précaire alors que les températures
descendent parfois jusqu'à -10 ou moins
15 degrés
un virus qui circule et je les attrape
et
j'ai peur pour ma maison pour les
maisons de mes amis
j'ai très peur pour tout le pays
et bien sûr pour moi aussi
et la situation est encore plus
désastreuses au sud-est dans la ville
portuaire de marioupol totalement
assiégés est coupé de toute
communication les autorités ukrainiennes
dénonce la terreur exercée par l'armée
russe contre cette ville où les corps
s'entassent dans des fosses communes les
habitants sont privés d'électricité
d'eau et de nourriture en attendant
toujours la mise en place de couloirs
humanitaires pour pouvoir quitter la
ville